PROFESSOR: So now let's focus
on the steady-state transmission
rate, which is really the most
useful in designing a safety
guideline.
It's also the most
conservative because
the transient transmission
rate is always
smaller than a steady state.
So, our formula for the
steady state transmission rate
is shown here, in
terms of the relaxation
rate, lambda_c(r), of
the aerosol concentration
in the air, and
also n_q(r), which
is the density of infection
quanta in the air, per radius.
So let's sketch some of
the important functions
here as a function
of radius and try
to get a sense of how we can
maybe simplify this expression.
First of all, we've
already defined
C_q, which is the
integral of n_q(r),
dr. This is the critical
disease parameter, which
is the infection quanta
per exhaled air volume.
I don't mean to cross that out
but rather just to do this.
So C_q is a very
important quantity for us
and we will return to that.
That's the quality
that we're going
to want to fit to disease data
for COVID-19, specifically.
And this will be the exhaled
infection quanta per air volume
and we'll typically
want to measure
that sort of peak
infectivity of an individual
in order to design the
conservative criteria.
So what is C_q?
If I plot this n_q, it has
a bunch of factors in it.
So it has the roughly
constant assumed viral load
per liquid volume, it
has the infectivity,
which we've already
argued should be smaller
in larger droplets because it's
more difficult for the variant
to diffuse out of those droplets
once you get above, say, 5,
10 microns, if not less.
There's the droplet
distribution itself,
which depends on the
type of respiration
but often has a peak
which is submicron
and then sort of a fairly
broad tail at the higher end,
with smaller amounts
of larger droplets,
and then V_d is 4
pi r^3, which
is just the volume of a drop.
So this net quantity,
n_q has some kind
of peak around 1 micron
or less and then a tail.
And then in the
integral here, we
have the integral of n_q over r
is c_q, so that's very important.
But there is these other
factors, p_m and lambda_c,
or 1/lambda_c.
Each of those
quantities gives us
a cutoff which makes
the larger droplets less
important for this problem
of airborne transmission
in a well-mixed room.
So lambda_c, as you
can see, is a bunch
of constant factors except
for the sedimentation rate.
So this lambda_a times
(r/rc)^2,
that is the sort of
radius-dependent change
of the sedimentation rate
relative to the ventilation
rate, lambda_a.
So as you can see, this goes
like 1 plus a constant plus,
r^2.
So as you go to large
r, the inverse of that
is 1 over a constant plus
r^2, so it goes to 0.
So it provides a cutoff and
the scale for that cutoff
is what we called r_c, that's
the critical size of a droplet,
which is just
sedimentary at a rate
comparable to the
ventilation rate
because, really,
this is ventilation
and sedimentation which are
compared when you define r_c.
In addition to that,
we have (p_m)^2,
which is the max penetration,
or transmission factor.
So while masks are
100%, or very efficient,
filtering large
droplets which don't
fit through the
fabric or the mesh,
they're not as good
as filtering
smaller droplets.
So if you look at the
transmission probability
when you're down
well below micron,
most masks are not doing
a great job filtering,
they may get 5%,
10% if you're lucky,
depending the
quality of the mask.
But then it comes
down because you
start to have better and
better blockage of particles
by the masks.
All these factors serve to
cut off this distribution so
that we're not worried
about the large drops,
and we're interested
in aerosols.
But it does so, here, in a
way which is quantitative.
So we're not just
arbitrarily saying,
as it's sometimes said
in the field, that
say 10 microns or 5 microns
is the limit of the aerosols,
but rather, we actually have
a well-defined characteristic
size that can emerge here.
And the way we can define
that is by taking the full
expression for the steady
state transmission that is has
the radius-dependent terms in it
and write this as (Q_b)^2/V
times--
and then we'll keep the C_q from
the integral of n_r-- C_q times--
and then we'll imagine that
the remaining radius-dependent
factors, p_m and
lambda_c, are sampled
at a certain value, r-bar.
So what is r-bar?
Well if you know the
function is p_m and lambda_c
is a function of
r, there is a value
of r, which we call r-bar,
which is when you actually
do this full integral,
you would get that value.
So that has to be determined.
It can be done numerically but
you can kind of see graphically
where it ends up.
What we're asking
here is what is
the typical value of
the mask penetration
factor and the relaxation time?
Well, it's going to be where
the most weight is here,
keeping in mind,
also, that there's
more volume at the higher
side than at the lower side.
So if we look at how
much activity there is,
we might want to emphasize that.
So depending on the details
here, somewhere over here
is going to be r-bar.
What we're saying here is that
even though our theory has
all of the radius
dependents in it,
so if you know exactly
the type of masks
you have and you know p_m(r)
from experimental measurements,
maybe a lot about the
virion and how infectious
it is in different-sized
droplets,
or you studied sedimentation--
you have all these functions.
There's a well-defined r-bar
at which you can just
use this simple expression
in place of actually doing
those integrals.
So that's actually
useful simplification.
And in addition to
that, we can also
write this another way,
which can be useful,
is to take the mask
factor out and write it
as a quanta emission
rate, lambda_q, where
lambda_q is Q_b*C_q.
This is the quanta emission
rate by an infector.
So if you don't like this notion
infection quanta per volume,
when you multiply by
the breathing flow rate,
you're actually getting
how many quanta per time
are being emitted
by the infector.
And then what's leftover
is another factor,
which I'll call f_d,
which is something
we'll come back to later, which
is what I call the dilution
factors.
If we take the breath of
an infected individual
and then it ends
up being diluted
into the room, the ratio of
the concentration of infection
quanta, or virions in
the breath compared
to that which emerges
in the well-mixed room,
that's the dilution factor.
This will become important
later when we look more closely
at respiratory fluid
mechanics and we
look at the plumes,
or clouds, of droplets
that are being emitted by a
person when they're breathing,
very close to the
person's mouth it's
a much higher concentration
and eventually it
gets sort of swirled around
and mixed in the room,
and it reaches the steady
state values that we calculate.
This f_d gives you that
ratio in some sense
and gives you a sense
of how bad the risk is
from short-range transmission
versus the well-mixed room,
so we'll come back to that.
But this is a nice
simplification
for how we can think about
the steady transmission
rate in terms of several
key variables, which
I've boxed here.
And so we will now move on
to applying this to COVID-19.